dans quelques heures ils seront désignés
vainqueurs ces quatre danseurs saint
quentinois
ce sont les voir et on secoue depuis
trois ans ce samedi ils participent au
concours chorégraphique de plaisir c'est
une création de base hip hop mais de par
nos influences et notre formation en
danse c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
regroupe ce qu'on est donc c'est un peu
de la fraude la fraude jazz a un petit
côté a donc le hip hop est prédominant
on a beaucoup d'influx ans parce qu'elle
va nous permettre de toucher des gens
qui nous connaissent qui nous ont vus
évoluer quand on était plus jeunes et
aujourd'hui ils vont pouvoir voir ce
qu'on est devenu et surtout avant tout
ça nous fait plaisir à d'autres
dansaient ici quoi derrière leurs danses
une histoire celle de quatre rescapés
d'un crash aérien
le concours est proposé par
l'association plaisir oise unis cypher
on a lancé cette opération avec
l'amérique plaisir parce que donc notre
but avec la sensation issife rc2
loupé la culture urbaine sur la ville et
à travers plusieurs disciplines dont on
a beaucoup de danseurs dans le collectif
on
même si des graffeurs et des
photographes pour nous les danseurs bah
ça nous permet d'échanger de nous
rencontrer faut savoir aussi que dans le
hip hop c'est une culture où on aime
bien se défier aussi en amiante aussi
prouver notre niveau notre valeur pour
découvrir le talent des ouailles en
secours rendez vous le 10 juin
ils se produiront dans le parc du
château lors du festival escales
d'ailleurs